welcome to this video and after yea
rather long break from tournament
coverage I decided to to do some
coverage of the Sun newly established
super tournament in Norway I think it's
really just called Norway 2013 super
tournament it doesn't have a fancy name
um but I need to look that up i didn't i
didn't manage yet maybe it has some
fancy super classics whatever name well
it said it has got almost all top
players only chrome [ __ ] is missing he
got replaced them couple of weeks ago by
peter svidler so a very very strong
field including ya cards and of course
his reason for the existence of this
tournament um okay so i was going to do
um daily reports if there was around to
their thing to rest days on and i'll be
doing it did report but i won't do on a
super detailed coverage of the games so
all games but rather rather quickly um
let's start first round so cards and
against a bowl of which is quite an
interesting on match up to palo had some
very nice results recently is recouped
some of his yellow rating losses is
nearing the 2800 mark again okay so
let's see what happens cars are playing
once you form we got a symmetrical
english and dissolves fairly normal and
to power of now place d5 this is son
actually a line that okay um i can
recommend to two black players it's a
good choice to play as black him it's
also a way to play on with which you can
actually i'm easily get an advantage
just like if white is not not careful um
okay
Carlton takes and place d fall on the
most common move actually instead of D
for here or the most common moves now
let's say same are this 93 or castles
which can lead to the same thing like in
any case would retreat with the night
here to see seven and then set up d 5
which is some yes sort of the reverse
maroc see point with a five and see 485
and c5 and this in itself is a very nice
setup for black gaining space and yes up
Liam try to take over in this game it is
not exactly in Reverse tamiroxie because
white has this extra tempo and he's got
some ways to UM directly play for
something for example or cancelled d 5 a
3 as such an idea what the could befall
on okay this is some another story but
this is something i can recommend for
black I'm cards not ever played
differently play d4 and then this of
course fundamentally changes the
position like it's not going to play me
five now and he doesn't have so much
choice um yeah black has sharp
continuations here like a Bishop f5 for
example but they are not correct he took
now on d4 Knight takes and now a very
important like now only has got one move
available that gives him a satisfactory
position and this is snide to before
this important move to remember in other
cases why it would take and we can
blacks pawn structure for example
something like this of course is is very
nice for white you can always play
against e6 or blanket could also try to
take here and this is already yeah
fantastic look at this
like it's got terrible position so after
Knight d4 black really needs to play the
smooth that's not nothing else yeah now
of course it sells a tricky for what the
night is just hanging and what's what
supposed to do basically you can just
take that's not nothing else and now
black can exchange on the one with check
King takes 1986 and we have a
symmetrical pawn structure if God for
him against against four pounds I mean
only in two against two of course and we
only got CND file open and whites
problem is he cannot cancel anymore he
lost time with the king and will lose
even more time with it too to bring it
into into safety and allow the rooks to
enter the game on CN default white will
lose time with the King lists of course
the disadvantage but look at this one
right he's got the excellent cattle
membership in fact this whole line has
been a special a special weapon now from
the Swedish and Game Master wolf and
Azzam under son played this yeah often
pretty often and he won from this
position numerous games of course he
never lost one um he's not the guide to
lose at all actually especially with
white but he won a couple of very
impressive games just with this very
slight um advantage in activity and with
this great Bishop let's put a couple of
moves on the board and we see a bit more
about this they'll see that this bishops
are exerting some pressure and white is
also a bit quicker here to put the rocks
on on good squares will play king be one
to get the king of the sea file
this is actually not a very common plan
a normal way to proceed in this position
is very often just to play a king to e1
f4 and king to have to this is some also
a plan that has been played by Anderson
quite quite a number of times okay but
it didn't have a letter to set up and
this also looks quite nice for White
Knight a5 and tends to get a counter
play and now Magnus exchanges the strong
geez haven't bishop of course which own
now get this check is inserted and drops
back out yeah black hair played this
check on f5 let's check here to make
sure that this pawn is thriving only for
which blunts this bishop a bit in this
position um I can be can play a couple
of more simple moves be three covers the
square just want to put a couple of more
loose on the board this is all very very
easy to to understand yeah and how to
evaluate this position it's some very
very slightly more comfortable for wide
but it's not much he's got this space
advantage based on on the porn cium the
king on the queenside is potentially
somewhat better than the king on f7
because of the action is of the Queen
side and um it's just very little what
would white is having but so I believe
it's not so much fun to defend this
pollution against against Garza but came
to power of play down a couple of you
see on the King side and now went age
from this is some an interesting
decision him I'm not quite sure if this
was really necessary I mean to power off
as one of those guys
who really doesn't want to put up on a
passive defense so very similar to this
power of in this respect because para
also lost quite a number of games in his
career I mean relatively speaking it's
not like he was losing all the time he's
the best player of all time or one of
the best term for for some reason but
his power off at the same kind of um
yeah behavior of here he was worse he
always try to defend actively and never
just wanna put up a passive defense and
sort of defended only and now each for
typically active looking move by the
part of may be here was the position
where thousand could have tried to to do
something to imbalance the position he
just played Bishop c4 check but maybe it
was an idea to take him it's it's not
like I'm so sure but maybe this was an
idea I'm the possibility is on ideas to
play age five year to get rid of this
week pawn and then you would have an
extra point so black needs to do
something I'm the racketeer maybe attack
it and then after age five black gum
probably shouldn't take here because
this son can get tricky easily also
because of this smooth tending Bishop c4
and thumb like this in slide trouble
also here here these kind of ideas I
think after h5 black maybe should just
go a g5 and make sure that he gets the
g5 square for the night for instance
after taking this 95 @ at some moment
doctor immediately because a
seven-ninths but this is some may be a
good good way to to defend
position yeah maybe Cal should have
taken to to to get some imbalance and
this in the game um he played them yeah
normal kind of moves not c5 a
possibility yeah but it didn't
materialize and just optically here from
looking at it white looks somewhat
better but it's it's really not not much
going on ERG for if you look at this
this is the active looking move but
after this the Rope has nowhere to go
you need to retreat in this concrete
position let's say here and after this
you cannot defend the pot so through
gage toughness are really bad wyd needs
to go g4 and after this it pretty much
um straightforwardly went to a draw yeah
what always gets this sport bag and just
a couple of moves later they agree to a
draw yeah this wasn't played but sake
it's as sjosh asset as it gets so it's a
bit of a dull game I mean Carson played
it played it safe and got very very very
slight nibble maybe but it's not it
wasn't enough to to get anything
substantial against to fall off yeah so
we draw in this game it will switch to
to the other games let's switch to on
Arnold Aronian and we've got evil
and a ruler pass Spanish opening aronian
place a succeed yeah he actually makes
the sea place the Berlin once in a while
but his main weapon is the marshal or
trying to to get the marshal nowadays
everyone is playing this d6 booth a d3
move sorry 63 to avoid the marshal the
thing is that even in those here in
those empty marshals like Age 3 um yeah
even then there are nowadays the I
gambit ideas like this which are not
easy to refute it's possible at all also
a form is some kind of toothless
nowadays because of beef or so the ante
marshaled zoom really this form I mean
we really don't promise wide so much on
a professional level of course and so on
on a normal chest level even up to let's
say international masters or something
there's no problem in playing one of
those other lines okay d3 and now aronia
place d6 normally he is playing this
line and he's got good results with it
but now he varies with the d6 yeah and
now he takes the chance to get them this
game into somewhat lesser let's explore
the territories playing see for TM and
quickly this is some quite uncommon this
set up it looks a bit like um this um
botvinnik pawn structure which sometimes
occurs in the English opening c4d d3 and
d4 or even with black sea 585 the
curious thing is this Bishop if white
would have played g3 Bishop g2 look like
line would look like pretty standard
English opening the main drawback of
course is that divorce weekend for white
but he's got a firm grip on d5 and can
develop his pieces easily so look at
this ok and now quickly along young
tries to use the weekend d foursquare it
gone off got exchanged and that as well
yeah so we've got the opposite khalid
bishops just this mean it's a draw yeah
not really there are some ideas and i
think i'm the ideas are mainly for white
and this is because I'm this Bishop is
always really biting on granite on this
own default on okay you can argue that
this Bishop isn't great as well which is
actually true it isn't a great piece but
why term maybe has ideas to put it on b3
and maybe play c5 um at the right moment
to to improve the bishop and there's
also this idea when the bishop is on b3
on this diagonal will see 5 there's also
the idea to use the F pawn to play
against f7 so black is neat degli to be
a bit careful that why doesn't get all
this into into play but he um found a
good way to get counted play with a five
and queen before the sum is irritating
for whitey played to Quincy to avoiding
the trade now switch the Queen over to
the King side yep black is click here
with f5 initiating counter play
especially against the eff porn which
can be
pressurized with the bishop age six and
ten the game will see that with a
tactical shot here Bishop takes a lot of
difficult shot um we had some mass
exchanges here and after that um yeah
it's an extra pawn for black here but no
way to improve the position that's
simply this this thread queen a5 is the
only way to to prolong it a couple of
moves but after the capture and black
enters on each way he needs to do it you
cannot allow y tu to grab this phone for
example if you play some stupid move so
I'm black needs to be quick rook f2 and
after that we got drawn they repeated a
couple of times and then it is drawn I'm
not quite sure if there's some anti air
draw rule on applied in this time I'm
almost positive there is one it's really
rare that tournament stall to have that
okay but here it is a very logical draw
the rock is on the seventh white cannot
afford any slow move blankets upon up
already I'm sorry it's not open up you
returned it with kounya of course but
white has no choice he cannot allow
black to take those funds so look f2 and
after this this King offers all so
ridiculous because after this like is
simply better so on a pretty uneventful
draw ok the next game going to be um
Dora where is it yeah my camera against
one how
had Petrov defense or Russian Defense
very solid but how is it's not playing
that too often I think but the the
Petrov ism is popular among Chinese GM's
anyway for instance run you who was some
China's number one for a couple of years
and now is someone on rank two or three
in the national rankings but he here
played the Petrov very often for example
came this capture and Knight c3 which
nowadays is one of the the main
continuations white really has a hard
time to get anything after d4 d5 in this
structure ever White has a very
clear-cut plan developed the bishop here
or here Queen d2 long castles and yellow
depending on circumstances you might
even push here on the Kings side later
your king is secured um I does this is
actually something I always some tell a
white players to look at this um if they
ask me for advice what to do against the
Petrov because this is a very easy to
play you don't need to know much it's an
open position which after 1.e4 should be
a position type that you should be
familiar with or like to play and quite
often you really can caddie dangerous a
tech going if black really castles short
and in this game he does you should
cancel short very quickly Queen d2 and
now he played b6 in my database this is
a funny enough on not played at all lahu
b6 novelty maybe it's a it's my database
that is pretty up to date but it's not
like having all the games of last couple
of weeks um I didn't find the game with
v6 black
ideas of this little complete
development or maybe 26 and the main
moves are 96 or 97 years just starting
with p 6 yeah let some advanced couple
of moves this is important white first
centralized the night and after being
attacked very light is it bad if is the
kingdom and the nidus of course on very
nice square so we see that the camera is
advancing on his pawns aggressively on
the King side and it's already not easy
for black to play I don't think that
black is in deep trouble we should be
fine food before isn't deep no in deep
trouble but it's some not easy to play
this position those two pieces are
simply irritating and the light on g4
Andrew Conley for their they look
slightly exposed right now when 293 and
the rook job back it's possible that
maybe rookies haven't got some better
but it's um it's not easy to tell rookie
one and now I'm maybe Quincy age was the
tougher move black exchanged on only one
and now he faced the threat of rupee a
check rook e8 check iam but the question
is is this really a threat one how now
went age six and here in this position
of course rupee eight was possible but
Nakamura didn't play it let's have a
look at this this looks like a very easy
way to get to get something for why that
it's of course the main move by the
computer it assesses this position here
as is very good for for white
but the problem is if you look at this
now this Bishop is saying so we can
insert those moves the problem is just
from a material point of view of course
White has won the Queen against on
Bishop and rook but the concrete
position is I think quite um yeah
favorable for black is the wrong word
but I think black has some good enough
pieces and outpost to maybe have hopes
to actually draw this game it's not so
easy for why to make any substantial pro
their progress especially those two
squares are terribly weakened and it's
not clear how to make any concrete
headway for example you can also easily
you think of a fortress type of
positions just just for instance it's
not for us though if black would play
here just just to put it on the wall
let's adjust to think of something like
this how is some white ever going to win
this you just put the rookie end for
example it's not necessary to play that
passively but black can probably just
sit and wait and white needs to prepare
this only break that he's got left to
win the game it's not clear that you can
do that but of course 94 is even a bit a
bit too quickly a black does not need to
do it so quickly i think that the Queen
win here with rook e8 ms some very
overestimated by by the computer unlike
i will reply Queenie to which is also
the move that puts more pressure on like
it it a text of the night and this now
after Queen g4 is very nice white let's
say here and 95 now you threaten rupee
eight but it's a much more dangerous now
for example we dangerous a search
wrong word it simply wins the game black
I cannot cannot take it black and try to
insert this move and then take it but
it's still on not helping so much it's
possible to oops I need to switch that
off Queen g4 um takes and now Queen h5
this is actually very strong g6 and now
this sacrifice yeah this is actually an
interesting position if you have some
time on your hands try to find the most
promising attacking continuation for
white there are two moves that are
almost um yeah there that are very
similar can be two identical positions
maybe treat it as an exercise if you
want to look I think it's it's it's not
so easy to see this move beforehand the
strong move as Queen to g5 it's very
strong the idea is to play this move and
look II 62 g6 both is very very very
strong black simply has no roof here
compute the evaluations plus six so
black is completely busted instead of
Queen g5 there's also funny enough rook
is six with the idea to play Queen g5
Andrew g6 and against this black also
has no antidote it's basically the same
variation so this is why black cannot
play a six and it cannot take on g5 so
what is he supposed to do he played
Queen to c8 covering oops Quincy eight
and we should be three yay amongst
others with this vision of five
black again cannot really take now and
this is nice the light is now hanging
and yeah how to defend with like this is
the relatively best way to go hoping on
this this strong light look h1 and now i
just want to show the the next move
because i said so nice if black goes g6
now which is pretty much the only
rufiyaa and white has the very strong
self walk 9h 5 4 s funny to create a
fork yourself against your own business
yeah black needs to take and then this
strong move sacrificing a bishop that
cannot take this is an instant made so
after this check King g7 here f5 looks
terrible at first but I mean okay it's
not great for black but this is still um
something that needs to be played yeah
and at the end the corn promotes like
has no way to prevent it it's a very
very dangerous attack that Nakamura has
some drummed up here yeah this is what
one whole plate trying to get rid of the
Queen's yeah I can where I exchanged
numbers not much choice and here one
discipline only six that however is some
return immediately p 2 is also hanging
so what does some white some edge here
he's got the rukon the seven this is
just a very important aspect of the
position so I cannot draw arrows why is
this oops good I've got a bit of a neck
here strangely enough no it's looking ok
the seventh-ranked and to be honest I'd
of course did some preparatory analysis
of those of this game but I'm not quite
sure in the next couple of moves um
where one how really went wrong I mean
maybe this already is a problem thing is
now you've got this position here which
rised very quickly on this was a
lieutenant I mean the point is black
here for example can think about this
this kind of move of course it's not
comfortable look at this something like
this looks nice for what but I mean like
at alternatives to an to consider and
maybe play what I know what I'm pretty
sure that again that the computer
valuation here's are just wrong yeah in
this position the computer on Houdini is
only giving bite a very very slight edge
and I have a hard time to understand
that I believe that with good technical
player why should actually just win this
position I'm not I didn't write it down
how much I mean how Houdini exactly
access this position but I know that it
didn't give ride them a big advantage
and it's pretty clear that it's only
right that can win here we can go ahead
a couple of moves the thing is just to
pieces and those pieces are not too
shabby
now can we were activated this nicely
and now at the end um wants to get to
the CC to the g5 quad may you provoke it
to advance or just win it and in fact in
the game he just wanted here after this
position the wrong how I just moved one
how resigned he has no way to protect
the spawn after root d6 there's 97 and
this also gives away the crown um so
nice nice victory by nakamura but um I
am not so sure where exactly 1 how went
wrong I mean I didn't have enough time
to really look very deeply it's clear if
you go back here that you always was
under some pressure but it's not clear
to me if for instance may be here
instead of 95 which leads to this
strange material imbalance um if instead
of this maybe c5r awesome what Stefan
white also looks better here but I'm not
one hundred percent sure also I believe
that this end game with two minor pieces
black probably had chances to defend
better but it's it's very ugly to two
defenders with the book can easily lose
pieces is also meta off of weaknesses
everything is oops I love this black has
got multitude off for weaknesses on the
light squares so I'm not quite sure if
it is winning white is close to I'm sure
but I'm not one hundred percent sure if
you would bet your life on it okay um
what games are left kayaking Roger off
okay yeah a job office really am in bed
shape he played a very very um yeah bad
candidates tournament finishing last
last
with an o minus six or something and
disastrous result um okay let's see
kayaking going for before as usual but
with 93 on mu-43 he declines any ideas
of playing international call for
Kalashnikovs or whatever with would be
493 m as a good move to avoid those
those slides now job played the g6 yeah
this is of course a good move 36 very
natural he am very often also played a
five in this position but then okay g6
is not not a bad move at all right now
cam transpose and probably should
transpose into an open this onion which
is the accelerated dragon light and dumb
black is some traditionally believed to
be quite okay IM okk i can't play it
differently played Bishop b5 and this
now is a bit of a hybrid line between
this 393 as plate and the roscoe limo
the only difference to the russell evils
of course that the night is on c3 which
is knocked in the best square all the
time because lots of lines you like to
expand in the center of course the light
on c3 is not great for that okay Bishop
g7 normal castles and now he five yeah
if I've is some a common way to set up
your pieces in those closed position
positions on I'm not 100% salt on the
idea in exactly disposition because yeah
frankly because of the game continuation
maybe some more salad solid setups and
will were better look what happens just
to to make this clear white lost the
temple
yeah but improved the bishop neurons
before age six didn't want to have any
of this and now white played a 3 which
is a double purpose move it gives them a
square for the bishop and prepared
exactly this move before yes it's can
come an idea in this in this slide to
gain space on the queenside and plug
actually has a hard time to to answer
this if you would would grab it this is
really bad look at this and now white
gives us the opportunity to plant the
bishop on d6 and Daria we'll have a look
at a couple of seconds at this end how
is blacker ever going to make an active
move yet so this is not playable at all
so black basically needs to allow the
capture on c5 after this for example
this was played and now you want gathers
all directed against the later f5 of
course this is only possible if you move
the King away so keen age 7 and 95 you
how to assess this position I think it's
clear that dumb white is maybe slightly
better he's called extra porn in the
center and has good control over the
weekend g5 square
yeah some exchanges and Dwight now uses
g5 by the bishop the problem is yeah
black doesn't really want to take it but
can you can you on the other hand allow
it to stay wide them in maybe not here
but in some some similar cases white may
even throw a cement this was you find
this is just strong piece but it didn't
get so far maty to a sewn-in instructive
move allows the trade as the am I mean
not allows the trade prevents the trade
on f3 the nidus has got nice squares
long run maybe even d5 and with the c3
you're going to kick out the d4 Knight
look like not took and we have this
transformation which is some at first
you think okay is it white they've been
passive here it's got everything on the
on the back rank and like Scott on
nicely position it appears on default
but in fact white has a very nice
position the night is not doing so much
on d4 it's not attacking anything very
often you can just take it off and in
the meantime white has got ideas on the
B file yeah on the B file can play also
a 5 and this is not a great piece eng
seven and now aight white plate this
very nicely here drives on the queenside
here with a five trying to create the
weakness on behalf of them half open be
far yeah black really desperately looks
for activity yeah and this is simple and
strong exchange the only good piece that
black has now needs to take care of
course
oops this is not fun at all just blind
us away the game needs to take with
those with the sea pawn okay now white
goes Queen c6 and make sure that he gets
the b6 bomb this is pretty much forced
black it's a really in big big trouble
yeah it's an extra ball at the moment
and in addition this very strong um
advanced breaking of the center like
does it have much choice he loses a pawn
in the center anyway so why just grabbed
it and TM it's an extra porn + d 4 is
the weakness it's easily surrounded and
taken data can put a couple of views on
the world yep read job of resigned it's
just the day of the sip on there's also
no way to to do that after c69 the prom
is just dumb unstoppable always have
whoopsie fall for example something like
this here got this and now it will
promote yeah you let me notice that I
didn't criticize flexor moves so heavily
frankly I'm not so sure um what exactly
run wrong to to get really a lots
position I mean I like white better in
this in destruction with the nice easier
but um I'm not one hundred percent shown
what went wrong I mean I'm pretty sure
that white now here is better but what
should like have done maybe I'm after
after this some some slower moves on
even allowing this possible as possible
at once I'm not sure I mean like I
certainly am in slight trouble here but
he shouldn't lose in the way he lost
down in this this radium yeah very hard
to tell how it how it render went
downhill alright so let's have a look at
the final game the last game this is
some between Peter Svidler and John
Locke the camel hammer pretty nice name
of things before chess player and then
the hammer came down on my head or
something well okay let's see what
happened um okay if you if you don't
know the black play he's Norway's number
to his um even a schoolmate of magnus
carlsen so they did quite some training
sessions together in the past Angie's
very strong red mass in his own right
okay swindler opened with d4 and we got
a groom fault I just always I think of
pretty pretty cheeky choice against
maybe the work number one expert on the
grid fraud so swidler playing white
interior went for the Bishop e3 line by
the three Bishop e3 um in the candidates
I think you played another less
theoretically am demanding line against
gal fought with Bishop d2 here on five
but this time we get one of the absolute
main lines Queen a five-course attacking
this is the normal response 96 and now
look be one yeah we'll be one is some
not the most common move in this
position the most popular one is of
course roop c1 as played hundreds of
times rupee one is interesting though
the um yeah the point is that why does
probably probably threatening would be
five so black needs to react in some way
um probably um this sounds weird in this
in this context but in fact black can
play um something like this which looks
a bit insane but he can play this Queen
sacrifice and for a while it was even
thought that black um actually has
enough compensation this is nowadays I
think I'm not the case anymore that some
consider to be better for white but it's
still tricky okay but Hama didn't do
that the most popular move actually is a
six in this position and then rook see
one okay as white lost the temple well
in a way yes a six is the additional
move but this also weakens the square if
you if you look at the game this is
probably the best way to explain this
point black took here think about this
structure the most a six-year would
terribly we can be six of course a six
can make sense in some positions if you
have enough time to plan it to a 6 b 5 9
a-5 Bishop d7 rook c8 and finally night
c4 then a 6b five might make sense but
in general you never want to go a six
year because of just weekends so um this
is some why
a six is a committal moves okay but back
to the game we have this position and
this is similar to the roxy one line in
the other line Group C one line the
rookie is on c1 now it is on b1 it is
believed that this should favor white
somewhat and the reason being that the
rook is nicely placed on the B file to
attack the console black cannot easily
develop the bishop and later you got
those roofs on nando's on those certain
lines it's quite nice but then the next
couple of moves look very very young
normal and it doesn't seem like em black
has got any particular problems i'm not
a huge expert on this and now okay these
have an attack so black gown covered
this after we should afford this this
idea and blackheads now to wear a
principle which can play a 5-4 B 6 on
Mahama here just plain v6 you should be
five yeah this tries to control squares
and maybe threaten Bishop c7 and now
hama went five yeah and to be honest and
i think that like doesn't have any big
problems here bishop moves um there
should be seven he exchanged yet now one
of the one of the bishops here and now
played night to be seven in fact in this
position there was always also the idea
to go f5 which ad at first took some
really strong and because you ask
yourself what is white in playing now
isn't this problem with the king and the
rook facing each other but there's this
move which is quite strong the point is
that f4 is really have a terrible move
because of Bishop c5 a move that you can
easily make in
easily miss I mean okay not in this
concrete position your bishop is trapped
at all but beforehand you can easily
miss this idea and this is quite quite
terrible food like you never want to
play FR before if it leaves wide with a
protected pass on the default and black
has no play at all this didn't really
help so night b7 play bahama is nice he
wants to go here and this way also
pressurize the you frog pond yeah the
King needs to get out of the default
finally free 19 Andrew before yeah I ta
black had alternatives I think actually
that just my belief i can only speculate
here that hammer was trying to play for
an edge here maybe um I think that he
played a five but I think that f5 for
example was simple and good I don't see
any any idea even that what white can
play for 95 and it's 11 idea and now I'm
simply take on on c4 I can also play
books the eight it doesn't matter much
what I think this is the simplest this
kind of position is completely harmless
black will get the corn him and in fact
96 is a funny idea at least the idea
being bed after this this Ruby form but
it's not it's not so dangerous really
Knight f6 evilness play-doh I think that
f5 was was simple and strong and woody
from I think easily led to to find
position that black should draw without
too much too much hassle he played a 5
which is not bad I mean he's giving up
b6
getting you for in return and then on
top d 5 is also week it's it's a pawn
sacrifice really by white and he took it
so I think this is what what he
calculated just getting the porn but the
fact is that white has got two very
strong invading looks and this is
certainly enough to UM to keep the
balance but it shouldn't be a decisive
factor in whites favor look 88 or
subject and now f 5m again a move that I
think makes it more difficult to why not
simply a post on this heaven something
like this just a sample line to check
and here and why does never going to win
this in fact here he probably shot down
should cross the draw with with this I
think this was a relatively easy way to
draw I'm not so sure why why he went at
five maybe he was trying to go to to
play for edge I don't know um okay this
is not looking so terrible as well but
it makes a life more difficult now why
does on the seventh White has got those
hooks and the a pawn weakness while this
double group see a day they cannot give
a decisive check it's all covered so one
who gets traded this is so sensible and
of course black return to the sea 51
here maybe I'm
here they also want the bishop before
this position now it didn't play that he
played Bishop to d4 not to be from but
this Yemm is already young already quite
tricky because white will get the Jeep
on then you've got three against one and
just a single pass pour on the other
side there's also this excellent bishop
on the central post so like a sign
critical shape here he played Bishop
deform and after look B 5 which is quite
strong but there's no other way to to go
then to accept this enter and I'm not
one hundred percent sure how to assess
this of course um and those are
relatively standard end games with the
apron but this is not a so standard
version of it because both sides have
moved the F pawn which doesn't a cure so
often what King is relatively good here
it could also be on on g1 for example um
because under other circumstances that
say cons on f2 and f seven and the king
is on g1 black gets the pawn behind the
killer the rook behind the pond and it
should be a draw but I'm not so sure in
this concrete position it's somehow a
bit of an unlucky configuration from
like in the game mama lost this quite
smoothly um but I'm and I must admit
that I simply didn't have the time
tonight 02 to get to the bottom of this
it's
can look what happened I mean a couple
of checks the apron gets pushed and the
King side is also week fri black
slightly he combined this with age for I
was still surprised that how am I was
trying to defend here from the side and
not going to go behind the pawn really
it's too late now at them anyway h4 and
King e6 down maybe it was tougher to to
play h5 from yourself but um said slop
downs look nice still hard to believe
okay yeah I cannot account retail mean
in them in the game it was very smooth
because why just just won the whole King
side and here he just teaches covered
his stuff and got to this winning head
game which hammer now resigned and if I
got slightly more time and I'm less
tired i will look at this end game again
it's certainly critical for black but
I'm not so sure if you really should
lose it I really need to invest more
time to to look at this you can also
switch on a computer it it's just
nonsense what this thing is giving I
mean it's a it's it's simply not a not
reliable assessment you need to do to
analyze yourself and you can of course
get some help at the computer but it's
not like it's just telling you and then
clear evaluation terms that white is the
winning oh it is a drawn so um in this
first round we got three decisive games
wit loved eating hammer here kayaking
between a job off and nakamura winning
against one how so nice
start of the tournament the second round
which is play term on and the ninth of
May on it features the upcoming World
Championship set up between carbon and
and or not can be curious what is going
to happen there I'm not sure I think
yeah we should are they both advice
today I'm not quite sure it's got to
stop the white pieces so we can now look
forward to that tomorrow um oh then say
on first day the mind I'm sure when you
watch this video yeah thanks for
watching this and I'll be back with the
second round in just a couple of hours
bye